what Mona [ __ ] break don't hear me
screeching at you whenever you're
twiddling your Jordan girlies continuing
the exploration of God of War and the
mythology behind the game today we'll be
taking a look at broken sindri the
dwarfs who made Kratos his axe and help
him modify the weapon throughout the
game now quite a few people chose to
ignore the spoiler warning in the title
of the previous video so this is me
formally warning you this video will
contain spoilers if you do not want to
be spoiled then I urge you to click away
now many of you will be pleased to know
that the two brothers did feature in
Norse mythology where dwarves were known
for their work with metals and being
able to craft the finest weapons in all
of the nine realms Brock was originally
known as Brock here before his name
became Angus eyes and it meant one who
worked of metal implying that he was a
blacksmith the name of his brother
Sindri was believed to have derived from
the old norse indir meaning spark and it
was also the name of a hall where the
virtuous Souls would go after Ragnarok
in some versions of Norse and Germanic
folklore
sindri was instead referred to as a
three and along with his brother Brock
here we would cross some of the most
iconic pieces of jewelry and weaponry in
Norse mythology in the game the two
brothers still shown to be dwarves but
with Brock having quite a distinct
appearance as his skin is blue now for
those of you wondering if he was
referred to as a blue skinned dwarf in
Norse mythology the answer is most
likely no but I will say it's very
likely that the wolves were seen as
having a different skin tone to the
other beings that featured in Norse
mythology spending most of their time
working underground and in caves at
their forges we can assume that the lack
of sunlight would have meant that they
had very pale skin there are some
different depictions in Norse mythology
where dark elves and dwarves were
considered to be almost the same thing
so if we take that into consideration of
the fact that they would have been
working around coal and certain dirt all
day it's definitely not impossible that
dogs could have been depicted in a
similar manner to Brock we can interpret
the reasoning behind the brothers
different appearances in several
different ways he can be seen as the
makers of colorful acknowledging that
Dwarfs would have been depicted
differently throughout Norse mythology
or perhaps it was just on to further
highlight the differences in the two
brothers
and their personalities broken syndra
spend most of the game separated after
falling out with each other and we're
introduced to them both separately well
we find out the actuals made for a trace
his mother and was passed down to kratos
upon her death we end up in this comical
situation with the brothers constantly
insulting each other's craftsmanship
until they are reunited by trace and
kratos the role within the game isn't
huge but it's still fairly significant
with them acting as merchants and
craftsmen and they do also provide some
comic relief in a game of a fairly
serious totem proc for the most part
appears as a grumpy and angry mostly
just Kirsten and thrown insults around
his brother syndra another hand is a lot
more timid in nature and he makes it
apparent very early on that he's
somewhat of a germaphobe even at the
mere sight of blood on Kratos his acts
were bracha paced across weapons of war
syndra offers a much more intricate
touch and in order to help a trace and
kratos the two brothers have to come
together where they would eventually
create a new family seal to signify
their work for the rest of this video
will be covering broken Sindri with in
Norse mythology itself where the
brothers greatest involvement was
crafting Mjolnir Thor's hammer the story
begins like so many in Norse mythology
with Loki been in a mischievous mood it
was on this given day that he decided he
would cut the long golden hair of SIF
the wife of Thor naturally when Thor
learnt of what had happened he
threatened to kill Loki by breaking
every bone in his body after several
hours of pleading with Thor Loki was
allowed to go down to Sparta lion the
realm of the dwarves and asked them if
they could fashion a new head of hair
for SIF when Loki would eventually reach
far too high he was able to obtain what
he was looking for from the two sons of
Ivaldi who also gave him a ship made
from the thinnest wood and the GU near
the deadliest spear of all not wanting
to leave the Dovan cave just yet Loki
approached the brothers Brook here and
sinned early taunting them claiming that
they could no afford anything equal to
the three creations of the sons of
Ivaldi Loki was so confident in his
claim that he bet his own head on their
lack of ability naturally broken Cindy
wore extremely angered by Loki's
disrespect and accepted his wager as the
brothers began to work they noticed some
kind of fly or wasp flying around this
was of course Loki in disguise and when
Sindri attempted to squash Loki heel
stung in his hand
the brothers first creation was a living
ball with golden hair named Gulen bursty
which was capable without run in any
horse the fly then turned to Brock here
biting him on his neck a syndra pulled
from the furnace a second creation the
Magnificent ring named that up near
syndra then placed a piece of iron on
the hearth and told his brother that for
the next creation they would have to be
far more meticulous as any mistake would
be far more costly than their previous
to Loki once again attempted to
interfere stinging broke his eyelid so
his vision would be impaired but syndra
had already finished producing a hammer
of quality that had never been seen
before the hammer would never miss its
mark and could boomerang back to its
owner after being thrown the only flaw
that this hammer had was at his hand ax
was too short but despite his
unhappiness about the imperfect weapon
syndra named his creation Mjolnir mean
enlightening when Loki returned to
Asgard he presented all of the items
that he had acquired to SIF he gave a
new head of hair to Thor he gave the
hammer Mjolnir we ring in spear the
opnion gone near went to Odin and the
boat and ball went to fry ear
the gods were extremely grateful for the
gifts they had been given by Loki but
they still deemed that he had lost the
wager and his head will be given to
Brook here in Sindri when berkians
syndra arrived in Asgard knives in hand
ready to claim their prize Loki pointed
out that he had only promised his head
and not his neck the two clearly angered
at Loki's trickery decided that they
would be content with sewing Loki's
mouth shot before returning to their
Forge broken sin that he may not have
been mentioned to the extent of the
Norse gods but they were still
responsible for creating some of the
most iconic objects in Norse mythology
for the most part the game seems to do a
good job in depicting the two brothers
even having Kratos his axe work in a
similar way to Thor's hammer the only
real difference between the brothers in
God of War and in Norse mythology is
that the brothers seem to be quite
comical within the game but if we go by
the story we've just heard we can see
that the brothers were definitely not
fond of Loki's humor and they were
definitely portrayed in a far more
serious tone I hope you guys enjoyed
some context and backgrounds surrounding
brookie in sindri and if you did then
feel free to show your ideas and thought
of me in the comments below